peu
[Musique]
selon le schéma directeur de la région
parisienne
cergy doit être à l'une des cinq villes
nouvelles qui vont encadrer la capitale
pour dit on la sauve et de l'étouffement
et de la paralysie
situé dans le grand amphithéâtre qui
entoure la première boucle de l'oise
la ville nouvelle 15 cents habitants
septembre prochain quatre cent cinquante
mille à la fin du siècle si tu es
clapiers ou ville à part entière que
sera cergy c'est vraiment notre objectif
numéro 1 n'est pas faire une cité
dortoir et c'est pas simplement une
paroles verbales
on a freiné la construction des
logements en attendant qu'on est les
emplois et les équipements il avant de
commencer des logements il y à 80
hectares de zones d'activités qui sont
déjà attribuées à des industriels et
deux usines dont une représente 700
emplois elle sera ouverte au printemps
prochain
[Musique]
voilà le centre nerveux la tête pensante
de la ville nouvelle
la mission d'aménagement codirige
monsieur hirsch ce sont les pionniers
ingénieurs sociologues urbanistes
architectes ils font sortir de leur plan
la ville nouvelle
[Musique]
[Rires]
tête de pont la préfecture constructions
futuristes mariage béton verre acier et
tout autour de la préfecture va
s'édifier la première tranche du
programme
[Musique]
l'école d'architecturé déjà ouvertes en
attendant la construction de l'école
définitive en 1972 l'école supérieure
des sciences économiques pour accueillir
mille étudiants dans le même temps
suivront un centre commercial un centre
hospitalier tandis que s'installeront
bureau banques et industries
en un quart de siècle cent cinquante
mille emplois seront créés dès septembre
prochain deux usines seront mises en
service une d'électronique une de
fabrication d'emballages 950 emplois au
total seize sociétés ont déjà décidé de
s'implanter à cergy les 15 cents
premiers habitants travailleront donc
sur place par le raccordement au réseau
express régional ils pourront se rendre
à paris mais à cergy le loisir ne leur
feront pas défaut
l'été sur le plan d'eau aménagé dans la
boucle de l'oise natation voile canotage
l'hiver piscine patinoire dancing et
cinéma ils sont déjà ouverts exemple
sans précédent ou l'app la passion des
distractions précède l'installation des
habitants
[Musique]
non seulement ce cinéma marche mais qui
marche bien et en particulier le samedi
soir on vient de tous les environs dans
ses cinémas de la ville nouvelle
comment bientôt invités a surgi on vient
habiter à cergy comme on vient dans
n'importe quelle ville
la seule condition priorité aux gens qui
travaillent sur place
quels seront le type de logements
offerts l'irak tout parce que pour nous
la ville c'est le choix c'est un faux
problème de dire ce qu'il vaut mieux
l'individuel ou des appartements
il faut que les gens puissent choisir
vous aurez des appartements des
pavillons aussi bien hlm que en
accession à la propriété
il faut vraiment qui est le plus grand
éventail possible
quatre cent mille habitants en l'an 2000
peut-être à mi chemin entre alphaville
ou brasilia que sera cergy lee
alphaville ni brasilia mais une
véritable ville et avant d'avoir quatre
cent mille habitants
nous notre objectif c'est en 1975 d'en
avoir trente mille et 30000 qu'ils
soient heureux de vivre
[Musique]